[Music]  um Mother's Day the perfect holiday to  show your mom how much you love her by  reading her most ridiculous  texts on TV Jimmy Kimmel got some of our  favorite stars to open their phones and  spill like Anna Faris whose mom has some  opinions about her acting work we truly  believe you are the greatest actress of  your generation we do someday hope you  transition into dramatic work similarly  Kristen Bell's Bob also has Hollywood on  her mind I know that you know Jimmy  Kimmel and he's doing the Oscars so tell  him to give you all the winners so you  can give me the winners and I can win at  my Oscar party  Anthony Anderson's mom wants a Mother's  Day getaway in Sin City anybody wants to  go to Vegas and see my mother she's  standing room 1337 at the Mandalay Bay  Hotel and Adam Scott just wants some  earmuffs is it okay for a grandma to  lust sure just truly do not need to text  me about it  [Applause]  you